in Frankreich plant Stromabschaltungen
im Winter die Regierung trifft dort
jetzt konkrete Vorbereitungen arbeitet
mit einem Krisenstab an einem Plan
Haushalte sollen den Verbrauch senken so
gut es nur geht bis zu sechs Millionen
Menschen müssen damit rechnen dass sie
im Winter zumindest zeitweise vom
Stromnetz abgehängt werden Frankreich
plant ist also konkret für den Notfall
dann rechnet dort sicher mit
Stromausfällen darüber sprechen wir
jetzt hier erstellter Frankreich eine
führende Industrienation was sagt das
über unsere Nachbarn aus
es sagte unser Nachbarn aus dass ihr
einige Jahre lang nicht ausreichend
investiert haben in die Erhaltung ihrer
Kernkraftwerke die Kernkraftwerke sind
im Prinzip eine gute Idee sie haben aber
einige Jahre die Wartung nicht gemacht
auch wegen Corona und sind hinten dran
und das wird eben zu diesen Engpässen
das zeigt aber eigentlich nur
systematisch wie es Europa ist es ja
nicht nur das Frankreich schlecht
Darsteller stehen schlechter und bei uns
wir wissen ja wir haben das Versprechen
voneinander wir brauchen die Atomkraft
nicht wir brauchen alles nicht alles
wird gut ich würde halt sagen es zeigt
einfach die große Risiken sind und mir
wäre es lieber unsere Regierung würde
auch konkret sich vorbereiten und würde
vor allem noch mehr tun eben zu
verhindern dass es wirklich so weit
kommt das wollen wir alle nicht aber
auch konkret vorbereiten konkret auch
mal warnen konkret sagen das kann
passieren fehlen ihm solche Warnungen
auch helfen ja vor allem der Verstand
der verstanden ist glaube ich ganz arg
wichtig um die eine richtige
Entscheidung zu treffen wenn ich
Politiker höre oder manche Manager die
behaupten dass wir bald nur noch
Elektroauto haben 40 Millionen Fahrzeuge
auf einmal sage ich mal in Ladestationen
dann wird aber die Lichter hier ausgehen
also Wasserstoff brauchen wir wir
brauchen sauberen Diesel da sind wir
einfach weltklasse und überall wo wir
Weltklasse sind sagt der Politiker das
wollen wir nicht das wollen wir nicht
und dann wundern wir also ich bin da
sehr ich bin da immer ich wundere mich
eigentlich dass sie das Sagen und die
glauben es auch noch und jetzt wird es
Zeit dass der Mittelstand und und die
Unternehmer jetzt mal laut schreien und
sagen jetzt ist aber feiern die Schweiz
hat heute auch mitgeteilt Elektroautos
wollen sie runterfahren viel zu unsicher
die ganze Sache jetzt stellen wir uns
nur einmal vor Stromausfall sei es für
ein paar Stunden was bedeutet das für
die ja Automobilindustrie wenn da die
Bänder erstmal stillstehen
unabhängig vom Strom mal ja wir
verlieren an Arbeitsplätze wir an
Know-How wir sind ja ein
Industriestaat wir sind
Exportweltmeister gewesen und kein
Agrarland also wir machen nicht die
größten Kartoffeln das möchte vielleicht
paar Grünen aber das hat nichts mit
sozial
[Musik]
vielleicht eine zukünftige Welt gibt
eine Elektromobilität und alles was
effizienter ist wo man das ist alles gut
möglich wir brechen es aber übers Knie
und Bertone immer so als würden alle auf
der Welt mitmachen und das ist eben
nicht so und ich finde es übrigens sehr
spannend wenn man Automobilindustrie
betrachten ich Chinesen da gibt es eine
Firma die kauft die Motorenwerke auf von
den Europäern die aussteigen und dann
sage ich mir immer ja gut warum kauft
ihr so eine Art Bettbank dazu kommen wir
gleich noch spannend ich bin gespannt
auch Elektro aber die machen eben auch
weiter Verbrenner soll ich einfach so
was passiert da das werden wir ja ganz
äh ausgiebig gleich noch auf die mobile
Industrie das ist ja auch ihr Thema
heute mitbringen das besprechen wir
gleich noch ganz im detailreisig wenn
sie sowas hören von unserem Nachbarland
er wird jetzt konkret gewarnt stellt
euch darauf eine werden an Plänen
gearbeitet wie wirkt es auf sie haben
sie Angst haben sie Sorge dass es zu
Stromausfällen hier in Deutschland
kommen könnte sie sich da irgendwie
schon vorbereitet irgendwas gebunkert im
Keller irgendeine Vorbereitung getroffen
nein ich habe keine vorbeugen getroffen
und das ist ja in der Tat so ähm der DR
schneller das schon angesprochen
interessant ist aber trotzdem und das
muss man für alles halbe halt auch
thematisieren das ist ja immer gehiesen
hat gerade in Deutschland wir schalten
die Atomkraftwerke ab oder jetzt den
Streit und die drei weiteren Laufzeiten
der Atomkraftwerke und jetzt ist
Frankreich ja eine wirklich Atomkraft
Nationen ja und ausgerechnet die sagen
jetzt wir kriegen riesige Probleme also
scheint Atomkraft zumindestens nicht das
Allheilmittel zu sein wie das manchmal
dargestellt werden
prinzipiell egal was wir diskutieren in
Deutschland wie diskutieren auf allen
Seiten nicht nur die von Ihnen genannten
grün sondern auf allen Seiten Fragen
viel zu ideologisch also ich würde mir
wünschen auf allen politischen Ebenen
dass wir mehr pragmatisch diskutieren
und uns wirklich auch an den Fakten ich
komme ja selbst drum ich bin heute aus
Spanien gekommen also auch dort die
Verhältnisse und das was wir besprechen
sind keine rein deutschen Phänomen wir
haben nur die Eigenschaft die Dinge
immer sehr dramatisch zu sehen
[Musik]
gesprochen und denken sich würde gerne
versuchen so in unidologisch wie es geht
die Themen in unserem Land zu besprechen
mir ist einfach in all diesen Fragen
viel zu viel Ideologie bleiben wir
einmal noch pragmatisch Sebastian bist
du vorbereitet bereitest du dich auf
Stromausfälle vor ehrlicherweise gar
nicht man sollte das wahrscheinlich tun
in Wahrheit ist es so ich habe
wahrscheinlich nicht mal ausreichend
Tiefkühlpizzen da und wenn ich die hätte
ist die Frage was mache ich denn dann
bei der Elektroherd geht ja nicht mehr
darauf
die meisten Menschen in Deutschland sind
darauf so nicht eingerichtet das kann
man als Privatperson auch kaum ich kenne
die Situation aus Südafrika aber sehr
vielen Jahren oft Hinreise da gibt es
diese Stromabschaltung da ist es
tatsächlich so Südafrika sondern
schweren Energiekrise da wird dann
einfach mal also von 16 bis 22 Uhr ist
der Strom weg wenn ich damit Leuten
telefonieren will in Kapstadt heißt das
ruf mich mal nach 22 Uhr und dann haben
wir wieder Strom Leute wussten sich da
aus mit irgendwelchen Batterien die sie
danach laden können
Katastrophenschützer Ralf Diesel hat
auch gesagt zu bereiten wir uns darauf
vor dann wieder so ein bisschen
zurückgerudert aber es gab ja zumindest
mal die Aussage man soll das ja kann
nichts tun das stimmt natürlich nicht
wir können schon vorräter haben also sie
sollten Wasser haben zu Hause stellen
Sie einfach dran ohne Strom können Sie
auch wahrscheinlich nicht mehr spülen
das kann auch unangenehm sein also sie
brauchen wasserverräte sie brauchen
etwas zu essen was sie sich machen wahr
machen können oder was eben kalt essen
können oder sie haben irgendwie den
Schwiegertochter es gibt für
Möglichkeiten sich vorzubereiten und was
mir eher die Sorgen gemacht für Sie auf
dem Land ist es noch vielleicht eine
mögliche Situation die Angel nicht
angenehmer die vertretbar ist aber eine
große Städten weiß man ja von den
Szenarien wenn dann Stromausfall ein
paar Tage andauert dann herrscht
Probe will ist noch schön ausgedrückt
vielleicht ganz kurz einhaken dass man
Sie vorsorgen soll nicht kommen von der
Stadt Pforzheim wir haben 130/100
unterschiedliche Nationalitäten 60%
Migranten wie sollen die Wasservorräte
oder Essen Vorräte vorsorgen es geht gar
nicht wir haben gleich die Möglichkeit
es sind Zimmerwohnung mit sieben Leute
das funktioniert nicht also ich bin der
Meinung man soll also wenn man jetzt mit
dem Auto auf der Autobahn fährt dann tut
man sich ja auch nicht vorbereiten dass
jetzt der Reife kaputt geht
und jeder denkt dass er da passiert
nichts also wir müssen unsere
Energieversorgung so gestalten dass man
uns nicht vorbereiten müssen das wäre
mir viel lieber ich komme ja von der
Auto
Automobilindustrie wir sagen immer das
Auto muss so gut sein dass man nicht
reparieren müssen und ich finde unser
Staat hat die Infrastruktur in
Deutschland so gestaltet dass man immer
reparieren müssen das ist der
Unterschied wir brauchen mal wieder
Ingenieure also Politiker die voraus
denken
agieren und nicht klein laut denn die
und denken ja nur so weit bis die Wahl
kommt als zwei Jahre gewählt dann machen
wir wieder Wahlkampf das muss aufhören
ich meins ganz offen sonst schaffen wir
Deutschland ab aber wir schaffen
wirklich sie sind aus Deutschland nicht
mehr interessanter sich selbst wir sind
ja auch Politiker ja klar
ich bin auch ein Mensch
bin
nein nein das ist ja der Unterschied
dass ich ja ein Mensch bin der ja
pragmatisch ist der ja das sagt was
wirklich ist also ich bin vor Ort ich
habe eine lernstiftung mit 300
benachteiligen Jugendliche ich
vermittelt sie in das Handwerk im
Mittelstand also ich werde es nicht nur
von der Kanzlei ich gehe tatsächlich
dorthin wo es brennt denn ich bin ein
Feuerwehrmann und ich bin meistens dort
wo es brennt in Deutschland tausende von
Politikern die Kommunalwahl den Menschen
dran sind da müssen wir schon
unterscheiden wenn ihr immer so die
Politiker ja das sind sie ja auch ja ich
kenne hunderte die ehrenamtlich im
Kreistagen in wirklich in der
Kommunikation
zum Beispiel von Pforzheim nach
Stuttgart gefahren in Deutschland darfst
du gar nicht telefonieren wenn du Auto
fährst weil du hast überall Funklöcher
es funktioniert nicht in Deutschland
Digitalisierung funktioniert nicht die
Bildungssysteme funktionieren nicht und
jetzt sagen Sie immer das immer so
fleißige Menschen die alles machen warum
funktioniert bei uns nicht das wäre
ungefähr so als bei Porsche wir haben
bandmitarbeiter die sagen die sind so
fleißig und jedes Mal kommt ein Polo
raus kein Porsche ja also das ist
ja auch gut sein ich habe nichts gegen
Polen ich wollte mal gesagt haben
einen richtigen unterscheiden welcher
Ebene haben ich glaube die Vermutung ist
ziemlich nah desto weiter weg vom Volk
desto problematisch war die Politiker
also wenn vom Bundestag Bundesregierung
wir reden auch von den
Ministerpräsidenten und die
Landesregierung zum guten Teil die
Aufgabe das Problem uns nicht einfach
nur irgendwie zu warnen sondern
tatsächlich
zu erreichen
die Politik wir vermuten dass es nicht
genau aber sie tun